to ignore the climate crisis as our
country is burning
and our coasts are hit by
fierce storms to
be there to crush the affordable care
act instead of crushing the virus
what keeps me at night is that what we
saw that night was authenticity
on both sides of the stage the president
authentically a bully
joe biden authentically a decent person
who cares about america's working
families
but isn't just like a democratic or
republican debate that's the
exchange of ideas that's what we came
here to do
this is something quite different
undermining
our institutions undermining our
democracy
by the president of the united states
with no respect
for the office that he holds
so and that's
my colleagues don't like it when i don't
get enough sleep so
so in any event hopefully we can resolve
uh
some of these challenges to the to our
our great country as we go forward
right now uh we're at the table
discussing how we go forward with a
possible covet
uh bill uh again
at that table reflected some of the
differences
that you saw in the debate for example
we have we're hopeful that we can reach
agreement
because the need the american people are
so great but there has to be a
recognition
that it takes money to do that and it
takes the right language to make sure
it is done right so again we have
concerns about
a sufficient amount of money to address
unemployment insurance needs of the
american people
uh we have concerns about for example
how about this
as a stock example of a difference not
just of dollars
but of values in the cares act the
republicans sneaked in
a piece of legislation that gave 150
billion dollars to the wealthiest people
in our country
150 billion dollars in heroes act we
take
that out they put in 150 billion dollars
which is more money than they spent on
state and local in the cares act
and in the heroes act we had 149 billion
dollars
for refundable tax credit for the earned
income tax credit and child tax credit
refundable 149
billion dollars almost the same amount
in the interest of coming down we came
down
to 54 billion dollars just by change
changing the timetable but nonetheless
came down two-thirds almost to 54
billion dollars
they have zero in their proposal
they still want to keep a 150 billion
dollar tax
break for the wealthiest in our country
and have
zero in terms of a refundable
tax a child tax credit and earned
incomes at tax credit that addresses
the poorest of the poor when i sent out
the letter
saying we had this bill and we had
tremendous response
every possible kind of organization in
our country
who cares about how government meets the
needs of american people
supporting our legislation i framed the
legislation
in terms of what it means to a family
of four making twenty thousand dollars a
year
you probably saw that i don't have to go
into all of it but some of it relates to
uh
this these tax credits i'm talking about
which make a big difference
in their lives uh what happens in terms
of health care what happens in terms of
if they become unemployed it is it is
about
the children and how they their needs
are addressed
and that's how we have to look at this
so we're located from the standpoint of
a family making 20 thousand
dollars a year a family of four
and they're looking at it from the
standpoint of 150 billion dollars
to the wealthiest people in our country
that's why we not only have a dollars
debate
we have a values debate still i'm
optimistic
the um we have come to
kind of in the ballpark of some things
still way off in terms of state and
local government
state and local government our heroes
health care workers police
and fire teachers teachers sanitation
transportation food workers the people
who make it possible for us to be here
they make government function state and
local
we're still far apart on that we're far
apart on
again the fundability that we talked
about
already and uh again we are coming
closer online uh money for have the
our health provisions in the bill it's
just a question of the language
because we've had provisions before but
the language was not adhered to so
that's a question of language
we're coming closer on small business
but we have the
restaurant and small venues for
stages etc
we're not in agreement as to how those
though that all would be treated because
ppp
is one initiative uh that other
initiative is a grant from the
secretary of the treasury as opposed to
a loan
from a bank and we'll i'm hopeful that
we can work that out
but that's a big piece of the
legislation so they're just um
some examples of um
of of how we are trying to reach common
ground
then then of course all everything
always comes back to healthcare
healthcare healthcare healthcare that's
how we won the congress in 2018 it was
the most
the three most important issues for
america's working families
health care health care health care
their good health of course
but their financial health as well
so the president of course we owned the
very day that ruth bader denis
ginsburg left us 10 states were already
voting we're already
in a presidential election
he's rushing this so that he can get to
court in time
to be there for the november 10th oral
arguments to overturn
the affordable care act president and so
we're saying to everyone vote your
health
because what they're out to do is to
overturn the affordable care act that
means
no more uh benefit for if you have a
pre-existing medical condition
that means eliminate the preventive care
and and free
exam every year which is very very
popular
uh in our country what means being a
woman
one once again be a pre-existing medical
condition where you have to pay
more that means rolling back the
improvements in the medicaid in those
places where medicaid was expanded
uh to help those on long-term care
seniors and long-term care much of that
paid for by medicaid people think of it
as a poor people initiative and it is
for poor children
and others but it is also a middle-class
benefit
for a long-term care for seniors
and that there's some other things if
you if you're a
an adult child on your parent's policy
you can stay there till 26
not anymore under what the president is
proposing
the list goes on on the benefits that
are overturned
the time of pandemic
207 mill thousand people
have died 207 000 people
in the united states have died we passed
the one
million mark globally we have a higher
percentage
than our population uh to the number
with the number of deaths
over seven million people infected
and the president wants to crush the
affordable care act
instead of crushing the virus
and so again this rush to judgment
that the president is putting forth is
about
overturning the affordable care act and
all that that means
to america's working families so that's
a
what that is again on the heroes act
it's so called because again it is about
our health care workers our police and
fire our
teachers our sanitation transportation
food workers i listed them earlier and
more
they are heroes they risk their lives
many of them
to save lives and now they may lose
their jobs and when they do
they will go on to unemployment
insurance
services will be cut practice taxes may
be raised
they'll be on unemployment insurance and
and what good is that for our country
then again we've had i think
constructive conversations
of secretary mnuchin and i but they're
they have not uh
we are not finished i'm hopeful but we
do
come at it from two different places 149
billion dollars for child tax credit
earned income tax credit refundable
150 billion dollars for the wealthiest
people
in our country retroactive
doesn't have to do with a covert
environment retroactive
so you see we come from two different
places
that was the case on the cares act one
because that was written in the senate
it was a trickle-down bill
as we went in with our take
responsibility bill
came together and bubbled it up
with compromises but as you see it still
had
some of their um some of their
tax breaks in it that tax break in it
hopefully we can find our
common ground on this and do so soon
any questions yes ma'am
hi can you tell us what to expect in
these negotiations
over the next 24 hours will you meet
again
with the secretary will you will the
house vote on the new heroes bill
well i'm hoping the house will vote on
new here's bill because it is really
it's important
for people to see uh that we are
completely identify with the concerns
that they have
and how we have allocated the resources
necessary to get the job done
we came down a trillion dollars as a
compromise to begin with
we then went further for another 200
billion dollars as i said earlier
not undermining our priorities but
um realigning some things in terms of
the timetable how long they would last
in addition we took some things and put
them
in our negotiation right now where again
we
last night the senate passed the
continuing resolution that we passed
last week
which was a compromise that mr secretary
and i worked out
however we have to now be working on the
actual appropriations bills
so we move some stuff into the
appropriations
bills because that is imminent when we
first started talking about this was
almost four and a half months ago and
now we're in the
the time frame that we some of this can
be done in that time frame so
i'm i'm hoping that we will be voting on
it today there's other
other items on the floor of great uh
consequence to us and i'm very proud of
our members
for their leadership in bringing
legislation to the floor
uh that relate to the women who suffered
abuse
you know the issue in georgia and uh
just
i don't even want to talk about it it's
so appalling
about uh congresswoman pramila jayapal
took the lead working with the women's
caucus and will have legislation
on the floor about that and then uh
congressman malinowski uh has his
legislation about
kunan on the floor i hasten to add that
he
the assistant secretary for human rights
and the obama administration
uh has been a champion for human rights
and now you see these people um
violating violating who we are
as a people and again he is unfat
unfairly being targeted by them in a
violent way
and speaking of violence uh the
proud boys the president's friends you
know the proud boys who are celebrating
the green light that he gave him in the
debate
uh you may recall perhaps you don't but
i will remind you that uh a couple years
ago during the 2018
campaign i was in florida we in southern
florida we had the race of um
donna shalala and debbie marcusel powell
and the proud boys came it was a like a
press conference and volunteer
meeting they came and pounded the doors
and shook the bike scared
you know we signed up for this they'd
these people don't
scaring everyone and they had desantis
signs they were tasked by
uh the florida republican party uh to
come and disrupt that
meeting which they did uh and in a
violent way
uh so in case the president doesn't
remember that he could call his friend
governor desantis who was part of that
uh
uh that thing so yeah i think we'll have
that bill on the floor today
we will where we ended yesterday was
my concern about no money for the
refundability which is a very important
part of our legislation to meet the
needs of these people
and by the way it's a stimulus injection
people spend the money right away
injects demand into the economy
creates jobs and so uh that will contin
is my expectation that perhaps it will
come back with some
uh counter in
in terms of of all of that they seem
pretty wedded to their tax cut at the
high end
i hope they'd be wedded to a tax uh
credit for
low-income children and families in our
these country between union
administration have been going on for a
couple of months now
do you see this round of negotiations as
the last chance to get something done
before election day
they have with all due respect they
haven't gone on from
we had them early on and there's been
a pause and now they've called and said
they're ready to talk again i i never
i'm
i'm hopeful that they can produce
something i i i never say this is the
last chance until election day
although that's 33 days away even if we
were to come to agreement
on language and money the construct
we're pretty ready because of
the heroes act had its structure had its
um
uh alleged council approvals had the
cbo scoring and that but when there
changes their changes in that but still
takes time
so um i just think that if we come to a
place
that is hopeful that hopefully
we'll be ready to implement it but that
it's in the language as you know the
devil is in the details
so are the angels i like to say
you're hopeful i guess the cynic in me
says why it does not seem like they are
moving
at all towards your position at least
from what we can see publicly
because of the needs of the american
people i just
think at some point they'll have to know
that the american people have these
needs and the fact is that we are four
and a half months from when we pass the
heroes act
or three and a half months until we get
sworn in as a new congress
closer to a new congress less than four
months
in time when we set uh
inaugurate a new president of the united
states
so we we're getting ready for what comes
next
but we need stuff now and and
some of you have asked isn't something
better than nothing no
it can be an opportunity cost that says
we're
rewarding and wealthy because they're
wealthy they're successful
at the expense of the poor we're not
going to exploit the needs that people
have
in order to once again increase the
national debt
uh to help the high end yes
released on monday today that suggests
that there's nothing that can be
resolved on this yeah no relationship to
anything
it just says uh you asked here's what it
is
this is how we came down uh this is how
we came down
we uh shortened some time periods we
moved some things on to the
appropriations process
which is needs to be uh negotiated soon
if we're going to keep government
open as the cr uh uh indicates by the
like the 11th of december it is that
they have no relationship to each other
except to say this is what we are this
is what we are
pushing
of for uh but our members are very eager
to uh
and i am too and i i the
the joy of being part of a uh a dynamic
not rubber stamp no lockstep
caucus is is is wonderful i have to say
so
we have a lot of exuberance and vitality
and people worked hard our chairman and
our committees worked hard
to meet the needs with the science-based
academically
justified institutionally
respected amounts that are needed
whether it's rental assistance or
mortgage assistance whether it's food
for those food insecure in our country
whether it's uh
health care if you lose your job if uh
we have a provision in there to
uh to immediately
have people qualify for the affordable
care act with the highest level
of subsidy uh for uh for being part of
the
system uh it doesn't require an open
enrollment so it's
a very smart bill we're very proud of it
and we wanted people to see what the
possibilities are
has more to do with that than whatever
intricacies you had going
uh there with presidential cancels that
the vaccine is coming soon
would you be willing to get an fda
approved a virus vaccine provided your
doctor clears it
would happen let me just say and i thank
you for asking about the vaccine
because what we have to do is have
confidence
trust in the vaccine and that means
politics should have
absolutely nothing to do with how
the vaccine is approved i'm so pleased
that the
pharmaceutical companies have said they
will not market or promote
a vaccine that does not go through the
clinical trials
that are required for approval and the
approval of the advisory committee
that makes that recommendation i don't
like the
uh the pressure that the white house is
bringing on all of this and
the statements that maybe we don't need
clinical trials
as we normally do we can just do it two
instead of three and all that
no this has to have the government and
let me salute
the scientists at the fda uh and even
some of the people at the cdc
not not working on this project but
while i'm saluting
some of the people who have been there
for a long time
about the highest caliber of science now
back to fda
working on this initiative let science
determine this not politics and then
people will have confidence
in the product and again we're talking
about what the distribution of that is
and we have
a significant amount of money in the
bill for the distribution of it in an
ethical
and um with equality and ethics how
it would be distributed uh i'm not a big
needle taker
i mean i had a hard time getting my ears
pierced i'm not a big eagle player
i mean they have to talk me into the flu
shot under great duress
each year so um but if it serves as a
model to other people yes i would take
the
the vaccine if it is approved uh
by the regular order of things madam
speaker
yes ma'am that should be the last i
think because i have to go to my day job
not that that isn't this about the
electoral college
you have been speaking about the
importance of trying to block
republicans from
having the majority of the state
delegations can you explain
why you're doing this and what you hope
to accomplish and
maybe tell us some of the races you're
looking at well
no i may not go into that but well maybe
some
let me say this the president has made
clear that he will do everything
to undermine the integrity of the
election declare victory with only the
basis of those who voted that day
uh discrediting vote by mail
that's one the next thing he may try to
do
is to have a
chaos when it comes to a state joe biden
may win the state the state legislature
may be republican and say well we're
still sending trump
electors uh to the electoral college
they that won't carry really but it
takes time
because it will go to court president
loves to go to court and that's one of
the reasons that he's in a hurry
uh to beef up the court so he has his
protections
uh for all the chaos he would like to
call in the election there'll be many
many many court cases and we've been
involved in a number of them
under the leadership of of eric holder
who's done a great job under the
national
democratic uh uh redistricting committee
that is also working on this but many
stacey abrams you name it there are
all kinds of uh legal minds at work
attracting other
legal minds to protect us in the courts
and in the court of public opinion or
the president is saying to people your
vote doesn't count don't go
vote all that really the president of
the united states really
so if all that chaos takes us to a time
that could be passed the um
uh the date when the electoral college
is
uh must meet the president has said and
and some of the so i've been doing this
a long time because i've been watching
all the things that he might like to do
dismantle the postal system invite
welcome
russian interference into our election
vladimir putin should decide
who our president is not the american
people and all that stuff
we know it so tracking all that
i'm a former chair of the party i'm in
politics because i love the policy and
the issues and what it means the
american people
but campaigns i thrive on and uh
and elections so on the election
there are three phases the time leading
up
to election day which we are in and now
more and more early voting has made it
the election time as well as the
preparation
and the uh uh challenges to what he
might put out there for voter
intimidation and the rest of that okay
so the preparation and the early voting
election day
to make sure that his intimidation
and his threat of intimidation and all
the things that he has said
uh is countered and that people feel
comfortable to vote if they culturally
want to vote in person
i would advise them to do it early so
that
their vote will be clearly counted in
time
i would also advise them to vote by mail
if they have any uh
if they don't want to jeopardize their
health so
you asked me this question which i love
to talk about so i'm trying to be brief
believe it or not
okay so then we go to the president
saying it is rallies
at his unmasked no social distancing
dangerous rallies i'm going to take this
to the
the house could decide this and he
points out
we have 26 republican states they have
22
so we have the edge in the house now the
constitution the 12th amendment to the
constitution
says the house you'll choose
if there's no resolution of the um
uh at the electoral college in a timely
fashion some of you heard this over and
over so forgive me for my repetition
as you may recall i said that
we will be ready we will be ready
and we are going to be ready the
constitution
clearly says a majority
so 26 is one vote away as one
majority we take one seat away from him
one state
just so you understand the house of
representatives
voting by state california has 53
members
of congress we have one vote
one state one vote alaska has one
member of congress one vote
so you see the unfairness of it all with
all due respect
to alaska wyoming north and south dakota
montana et cetera et cetera
so the um so that so we have
multiple opportunities where we can take
down that one vote
and we also have multiple opportunities
where we could get to 26 ourselves but
that's not necessary
no majority then it goes into another
range where the speaker becomes the
acting pre
it's complicated after that but our
purpose because your last question was
the
really the culmination of it what do you
hope to accomplish
by this what i hope to accomplish is to
send a very clear
message on election day to the president
there ain't no light at the tunnel for
you in the house of representatives
it isn't going to work so don't don't
cause
chaos because you think it will lead
to a light at the end of the tunnel
because that light at the end of the
tunnel in the house
is going to be a train coming right at
your plan
thank you all very much have a nice day